okay welcome everyone to lecture number
12 I hope that you had a good spring
break so let's get started right
away okay so just a brief recap of what
we have done so
far yeah this one so we are still with
the problem of operat learning and uh
this was too
big operator learning and we look at
this abstract PD which is right
here and this could be any differential
equation right it could be our ordinary
differential equation it could be a
stochastic differential
equation stochastic veral differential
equation doesn't matter the main point
is that uh the the sort of the problem
setup itself the setting itself so the
target what we are going to learn is
this guy here G the operator and this
Maps a function space to a function
space right so it takes the inputs to
the PD in this case the coefficient a
and the source F and it produces the
solution here so this is the setup that
we are in and just to recall from the
last lecture that we cannot parameterize
in particular what we can't do is we
cannot work with let's say finite
dimensional Subspace or a small
parametric finite dimensional Subspace
of the Space X we really have to work
with something which is uh which is
infinite dimensional in some sense or at
least a large finite dimensional sub
space okay so with that setting in mind
let me remind you what we tried to do to
solve this problem right so one way we
thought we could solve the problem was
as follows so we started with the input
for instance this the verticity field in
the nav Stokes equation so this was here
the verticity field in nav Stokes
equation and we sampled it on a grid uh
you can see that the grid points are
there this was a 16 by 16 grid but in
practice it's a 64x 64 grid
and then we applied the you could you
could have an MLP but we applied a CNN
so different layers of the CNN and that
gave us a finite dimensional output
which was also on a in this particular
cartoon on a 16x 16 GD so you take a
vector which is 256 dimensional and you
produce another Vector which is 256
dimensional so that was the objective
and then we could interpolate right so
interpolation led us to an infinite
dimensional
back into an infinite dimensional space
so if you do that then of course we
think that we solve the problem but the
reality is that we don't solve it mean
this was the this is the main point for
instance in this graph here as you can
see at the training resolution we got
satisfactory results but as soon as we
changed the resolution we got into
problems so this was the this was the
whole point of my last lecture that uh
you are not learning a function to
function mapping what you're learning is
a particular finite dimensional
approximation to finite dimensional
approximation mapping so you are only
learning something at the discrete level
and not the continuous level but since
we're dealing with functions we have no
choice but to work with the continuous
uh spaces right function spaces whereas
because of computation we have to work
with the discrete so that's why it's
important to enforce some form of
discrete continuous or continuous
discret equ right and in the towards the
end of the last lecture I tried to sort
of uce that maybe I a bit rushed so what
I'm going to do is to start
by start by recapitulating uh recalling
some of the concepts and perhaps
explaining them better okay so how do we
sort of formalize and formulate this
continuous discre
equivalence so we do so with this
framework which is uh called Reno uh
representation equivalent neural
operators right so this is the framework
that was introduced last year from my
lab but it essentially what it does is
it provides some sort of a notion proper
notion of this continuous discrete
equivalence and the key is this picture
here means this is this figure here is
worth a thousand words so let me try to
walk you through this figure so our
problem let me pick a color that is not
there orange is
good so our problem is right here so we
start with the function Space X and our
outputs are in a function space y so in
reality or in principle we need to
approximate this quantity the script G
the operator right the object that Maps
Infinite dimmension Space to infinite
Dimension space unfortunately we don't
know how to work with infinite
dimensional spaces we can't work with
infinite dimensional objects with
continuous objects on the digital
computer so we have to work with some
sort of finite dimensional
representation of it right and this is
provided by this spaces X and Y so these
are finite dimensional spaces these
could be for instance as you saw in this
example uh points on a grid right so the
function is an infinite dimensional
object its values on points in a grid
are a finite dimensional
approximation and then of course there
is a link between the infinite and the
finite and these are provided by
this encoding so let me recall so this
was an
encoding this is e this goes from
infinite to finite right and
reconstruction as the name Jess this is
a mapping which takes you from finite
and back to infinite right so this this
is the setup that we in so of course
what you ideally like do is to connect
the two right you want to say that when
I go back from the infinite to the
finite go from the infinite to the
finite and go back to the infinite I
don't make an ER and this is sort of
conceptualized or formulated in terms of
of these aliasing errors right so these
are the key key objects here aliasing
error and it's a very very automatic
error means for those who are more
mathematically inclined all that we are
asking is for this diagram here this guy
here to commute how does that happen so
let's let's try to understand it
remember that there are two ways in
which we can go from X to Y either
directly by the operator G which is what
we would ideally like to do but in
practice we would not be a ble to do
that or we can go from the infinite to
the finite so this is for instance
taking the function and putting it as
Point values on a grid so we do this
through this e here right then so we
come here and then we use the whatever
the MLP or the CNN that takes the finite
dimensional values on the grid to values
on the grid so this is this step here
and then we try to go back to the
infinite dimensions and to do that we
have to use this R here right so we come
down like this we work like this and go
up like this so this is a very very
simple construction and this is the
composition here and ideally by doing
this by coming from infinite to finite
working in finite and go back going back
to infinite we want to be exactly able
to approximate the operator G or exactly
able to realize represent the operator G
and this if you don't do so if you make
an error and this is precisely what is
the aliasing error this is an operator
because it acts on operators and this
error has this functional form right so
it essentially says that by going
through this route what is the error
that I'm going to make as long as it is
zero in per layer remember that I had
this layer construction because neural
networks are layer wise you will see
several at least one prominent example
later today so if I did not have this
lay if I don't if I make an error at one
layer of course the error can grow right
so maybe the error is only 1% in the
first layer but then it goes to second
layer it becomes 2% then it becomes 4%
8% you can expect geometri growth right
so that that can become
large so we want to stench it we want to
sort of kill it at the at each layer
itself and we say that we we try to have
operators so this is something that is
given to us right we cannot we cannot
manipulate that but what we can do is we
can design the E here we can design the
finite dimensional spaces we can design
the G here the r here such that there is
no aliasing ER so this is somehow the
objective the the mission that we have
the goal that we have and once we do
that there are several goodies that come
our way but this construction is
absolutely essential and sort of the
core of operator learning is that clear
are there any questions here because
last time I I rushed this so I thought
that I would try to explain it again and
we will do a couple of concrete examples
today so you'll see
that really hit by the poogies so I'm
struggling a
bit okay so then what is the first
goodie that drops our way so first of
all this is structure preserving in a
sense that what you do at infinite
Dimensions is mirrored in a finite
dimensional world so there's exact
mirroring of what happens between the
two and an immediate consequence which
is something which we realized is an
issue if you remember
that once we change the grids we were in
trouble right so let's see what happens
if we change the grids or change the
resolution or representation for that
matter then we have this picture here so
now we have in two different grids so
for our purposes here this this is more
abstract than just grids but for our
purposes here just imagine that you have
two different grids right so you have a
grid which is given by the operator is
given by G and you have another grid
where the operator is given by G Prime
okay so now we want to connect the two
we want to say that if I train on G and
if I go to G Prime and I test on G Prime
I shouldn't be making an error or at
best I should be making a small ER right
let's ideally I shouldn't be making but
the point is how how do you do that so
if you have this Reno property if you
know that there is exact mirroring
between the continuous and discret this
is a triviality why is that so remember
that I want to go between G and G Prime
so what do I do I been I I'll work out
an example in the next slide but let's
let's look at this abstract concept so I
have a mapping which takes X the
discrete space values on a grid to Y
another discrete space values on a grid
through the mapping G but I know that
there is an exact mirroring to The
Continuous and how do I go to the
continuous I start with uh so how do I
go to the continuous how do I realize
this I start with maybe it's uh
incorrect here or remember that we
always have this formula here right
maybe it's the other way around that the
continuous is represented by the
discrete in these forms right and
similarly I have another grid here G
Prime where the same representation
holds so I have the same representation
here and the same representation here
now I want to go from G Prime to G right
I want to use G Prime and G together so
what do I do I start with G Prime right
I start with G Prime but I know that
from G Prime you can go to this operator
G here and how do I do that first I use
this RP Prime so to go from here to here
then I use this mapping and then I can
come back so this is the mapping which
is given here okay straightforward but I
know that this mapping here is given in
this form so in order to realize this
mapping I go back through here to the
final dimensional Space X use G and come
back and I compose the two okay when I
compose the two so to go from G Prime to
G what I do is first I go from X Prime
this is the discrete space let's say
resolution on a grid first I go so this
is the operator here I go to my infinite
dimensional space here and then I go to
this finite dimensional space so this is
this block which expresses that I work
with this finite dimensional space which
is given here and then again you know to
do so I go back to the infinite
dimensional space right and come down
and this is the this is the formula
which is given here and remember because
this diagram commutes whether you use
the direct evaluation or whether you use
this you get the same answers okay so
this is a very very simple construction
you just compose these two diagrams and
once you compose these two diagrams you
know how to relate two different
discrete repres presentations because as
I said in practice if you remember in
the last lecture I also had a picture
about it you don't have a mean there
could be multiple discrete
representations multiple grids on which
I can represent the function and the way
in which I relate them I will do a
concrete example in a minute is
precisely through this construction that
you start with one particular grid go to
the continuous level and then come back
to another and then come back you see so
this is the way in which you can move
between GRS and then it's a sort of very
elegant way of moving between grds any
questions on
this let's work out an example just to
sort of concretize also people on Zoom
if you have any questions don't hesitate
to ask it in the chat box
okay so let's do an example just to just
to realize this um in some concrete
these constructions in some concrete
manner okay and then we will check for
different architectures whether this
holds or not so I just take a very very
simple
example 1D this can be done in multid
there is there is no issue there and
let's take um a
picture so let's take so this is 1 D
let's say this is a unit interval and
let me draw some picture of a
grid just for our visualization like
this you can't have a g with three
points but just for our visualization so
we have um this is the discrete
representation this will be my grd G and
what is my continuous so usually when
whenever you have given functions these
functions belong to some subol spaces
some spaces of continuously
differentiable functions twice
continuously differentiable functions
and so on so to realize these
constructions these function spaces are
too big so we have to work with let's
say smaller function spaces and this
this is well Justified okay this is is
well justified in most cases at least
for PDS this is well Justified so
instead of working with this very
complex uh spaces like Square integrable
functions what we're going to do is to
look at infinite dimensional subspaces
of them and the space that I introduced
last time is a space of band limited
functions so what are band limited
functions these come from signal
processing just for Simplicity mean this
is not a regist definition by any
means you know that any function let's
say perodic function U of X can be
written as UK K sin K pix for Simplicity
right and all that you do is that you
truncate the number of frequencies to
some capital okay so you have a function
you expand it in sinusal basis we will
we will look at the Fier transform later
but let's say for Simplicity you have a
Fier basis representation okay and then
you expand it in the for year basis and
you just say that the high frequencies
Beyond a point don't matter of course
this can be suspect because some
functions have lots of frequencies but
at some level there is only white noise
which has uh equal content in every
frequency that's why it's white noise if
you have any structure in a function
what you know is that Beyond a certain
frequency the frequencies are going to
Decay so essentially I can sort of throw
them out we will have we'll see a
rigorous version of this argument not in
the next lecture but in the lecture next
week okay but so this is the first step
that we are going to deal with functions
which have finitely many frequencies
could be 100 could be 200 you know
something something large but in
practice it's probably less than that so
in other words the support of its Fier
transform so essentially the support of
the F this is a FIA series version of
that the FIA transform version is that
it is sort of compactly supported within
some band right so here the FIA series
is truncated Beyond a certain point so
these are band limited functions and
this is a particular example you could
think of some other functions and this
corresponding operators are going to
change now what is the encoding in this
particular case so this is given now
these are band limited functions
right the encoding in this particular
case you can work with pointwise
evaluations so you take a function so
whatever function that you
have just just an example and you just
take its values on the grd so you take
this take this value the value here the
value here and so on
okay so this is the values on the grid
so this is the encoding and what is the
Reconstruction so Recon encoding takes
an infinite dimensional object a
function which is given in green here
and takes represents it by a finite
dimensional object so in this case just
a three Vector representing the values
of the points all right and then to
reconstruct the function we have to go
back from something which is finite
dimensional back into the infinite
dimensions and this is done by in this
particular case by using what is called
a sync basis so all of you should know
what is a sync function so sync of
X I could get the constants wrong here
but morally it is s of X by X right so
this is this is roughly sync function
and then what you do is that if you have
been given um um finite L many
quantities VJ so you take VJ so this is
the values in the grid and then you just
form this basis expansion so this is the
sync basis right and as long as your
grid is dense enough so let's say that
your cut off frequency is K right and if
the number of points is twice that or a
little more than twice that then you
have a very famous theorem from signal
processing harmonic analysis which is
called the NIS Shannon theorem what it
tells us that whether we work with the
function itself or whether we work with
the values in the grid there's a one to
one correspondence okay so how many of
you know about the Shannon theorem
everyone should know somehow right so
all that it says is that if you have a
denson of grid for these band limited
functions then you can represent it just
by the point values in the grid but if
you don't have a then of grid then you
get what are called classical aliasing
erors
okay I usually have a picture but now I
don't don't seem to have this uh so the
the picture is if you take take um sin 3
pix and sin 20 pix and if you don't have
enough resolution these two functions
will agree at many points so you cannot
distinguish between them right it's very
easy to read it up for instance on
Wikipedia there is a nice article on
this so the setup is very clear so you
have a bje bje means one one everything
is uh sort of equivalent there is a
complete mirroring provided that you are
in this setup so this is B lied these
are values in the grid this is uh the
sync bases this is just the point values
taking the point values of a function
and you can do the same at the output
level so you can also do the same at the
level of this grid okay so now aling
error is just Computing what is going to
be the difference between these two
because r e these are all okay so all
that you have to do is to ensure that
your G is such that this quantity is
identically equal to zero okay so this
is a straightforward task to check and
another way to think of it is how this
program is realized what happens when I
move between the two grits so let me try
to explain this a little bit so let us
say that I have a g which is Sereno
which is areas free and it has taken
values or it has been trained on these
three point values just for Simplicity
now let's refine the grid right let's
take the black
here and let's take take some additional
right this one let's take some
additional points let's take that these
are your new points
right so how do I evaluate this how do I
know that this is going to work out so
now remember that my input now are
values on the new grid so the values on
the new grid are the squares as well as
the circles right so this is the new
grid squares as well as the circles so
this is a finite dimensional object
right so the first thing that I do is
that since it's a finite dimensional
object I want to go to infinite
Dimensions how do I go to infinite
Dimensions I use this basis here so I
have a finite dimensional object let me
call it as V1 V2 up to V7 in this
particular example I go to infinite
Dimensions I know the positions of these
points so I go to infinite Dimensions
using this sync PES no no problems I'm
assuming that my density in both cases
is enough so that the conditions the
nuist barrier is satisfied I can
represent the functions so now I am at
infinite Dimension this is a function
and then remember that I have to project
back to the original so the original
grid is just these three points this guy
here this guy here this guy here so I
have this new function which is infinite
dimensional and I can just evaluate it
at these these three points right so I
evaluate the function at these three
points so I just uh the these these
three values here then I use my operator
the neural operator that I have designed
this G here this will give me the value
again at these three points right so it
takes three points it goes back to three
points again no problem so this is a
finite dimensional operation and then
remember that I have to go back to my
new grid so what do I do I again go back
to my infinite Dimension by this
reconstruction so now I have been given
some new values here let me call them as
we had one we had two we had three and
once I have this I again use the sync
bases go back to infinite dimensions and
then I evaluate them at these new values
that's all I evaluate them at all of
them so in in a way I'm performing sync
interpolation twice and then I have I
I'm completely there is complete
Fidelity here between the infinite and
the finite dimensions and then I can
realize that this formula tells me that
this error is going to be zero ideally
okay if you construction is solid this
error is going to be zero so this is a
concrete way in which you can evaluate
you can go between grids that you start
with a particular grid seven points
construct the function in of course you
never going to construct actual function
because that's an infinite dimensional
quantity there's no point in doing that
evaluate it on the new grid do all or on
the old grid rather in this particular
case do your operation which was anyway
trained on the old grid go back again to
the infinite dimensions and then project
back to the okay so this is the this is
a systematic procedure in which you can
go between these spaces and this also
explains to you how this link between
the infinite and the finite Dimensions
Works in practice okay so is this
example clear so this was precisely uh
sort of I I did it in a manner so that
you can understand this this particular
construction so my suggestion is
afterwards go home try to understand
this and if there are any questions you
can always ask me in the next Le
okay so let's move on and this uh tells
us that first of all the the original
this starting of the story was this this
particular guy right which somehow has
the same flavor but there's something
which is missing which is this
continuous discrete
equivalence and then of course we
realized that I did it very quickly
that's why I'm repeating it because I
felt that one needs a proper explanation
so the first thing was of of course the
fact that CNN's as we expect these are
not Renos means this
is I'm not able to
change what does that mean remember that
CNN are nothing but discrete
convolutions so you have been given a
signal which is on let's try to expand
this a
little how does it
look because I for me it's very
difficult to see when when it's in small
print okay so as you can see so you have
um signal which is given on a grid so
this could be band limited functions for
Simplicity right and then what does the
CNN do it doesn't do this sort of
complicated gymnastics that I just
explained that's why it doesn't work of
course but what it does is that it
always has this uh convolution kernel
which is given by some K okay so
graphically I'm representing this by
this kernel here okay all that it does
is that it so there is a window so for
each point it just multiplies these
three points gives you a value then it
moves on at the next level it goes to
these three points then these three
points and so on so this is the this is
the way in which CNN works and what is
being trained during the training
process is of course the kernel right
because the coefficients of the kernel
are what are unknown to us and these are
the things that are being trained so the
kernel is fixed now when you go to a new
grid so as you can see this grid is a
refinement of the grid just exactly in
the sense that I did before this is a
refinement of the grid I have added a
few points I can also reduce points mean
that's that's that's equivalent and
again I'm assuming that the density of
the points is such that this neist
condition is satisfied and there is a
fidil there is some bje essentially
between the continuers in the district
now what happens so I have this trained
kernel this is the training process I
train the kernel and I want to evaluate
it on the new grid convolution makes it
very simple you don't have to do any
fancy things I take the train kernel and
I just keep on multiplying uh with the
new points okay so I take these three
points and I multiply now I change the
color then I take these three points and
multiply these three points and multiply
I have a train kernel so there there's
this just evaluation this can be done
very very fast but now you see what the
trouble is right so the trouble is that
if I just focused on on this point I
just have to focus on one particular
Point okay let's use the black here so
let's focus on this particular point so
for the grid the this course grid here
my convolution kernel would have
multiplied these three points right now
for the same grid point which is here
this would have multiplied these three
points it's the same con but it's
multiplying different points or values
at different points and of course the
signals amplitude is different at these
points it's a it's a smooth functions so
these are not very very different but
they are different so what does it mean
that per evaluation you since you're not
doing all this uh gymnastics you're not
doing this s interpolation automatically
what happens is that you get different
values right so you definitely have
different values when you multiply with
these three points or with these three
points right there is there is going to
be different different values you make
an error
yes this is what we will do later as
you'll see this is an important point
you have to use you have to resize your
convolution kernel in some automatic
manner otherwise you cannot but with the
CNN the the picture that I produced I
was not doing this right so this is this
is the essential point that that is to
be remembered so here I was not doing
this I was using the same kernel and I
was just window it across I can do it no
one no one stops people were doing it
and then you see what the what the
effect is going to be so now because of
this uh thing you make errors and you
see what you see so there is no there is
a resolution dependence here there's no
resolution Independence and as a result
CNN's are not they're neural operators
in the sense that you can always take an
infinite dimensional object and you can
map back to infinite dimensions that's
straightforward right but the fact that
they don't have this structure
preserving property means that they will
make eling errors and these things will
accumulate right so this is a very very
important point that we should we should
remember so essentially I repeated the
contents of the last lecture at some but
I needed to do so I realized that I was
too quick okay good any further
questions on this so this doesn't work
so our first approach that we use
doesn't work so what are we going to do
now so let me introduce some
Alternatives so in the next few lectures
we will look at different kinds of
Alternatives and already start with an
Alternatives that you have seen in uh
your tutorials because tutorials are
little ahead because next Monday there
is a holiday So eventually we will catch
up it has been done on purpose also I'm
teaching very slowly so anyway so the
first alternative that we are going to
deal with is what are called neural
operators and they have been around for
everything here is fairly recent right
like 3 years they've been around
relatively long within this time scale
right so they were introduced at least
formalized by the group in CCH Nick
kachki was the first author and the idea
is extremely simple idea is also elegant
right in in some sense so what you do is
a follow remember that what are neural
networks at the end of the new day
neural networks are compositions
remember that this this is my definition
of neuron networks these are
compositions of different layers and
each layer has a particular structure
and the particular structure is it takes
a vector y right and it outputs another
Vector let me call it as Z ZK in this
particular case so ZK + 1 or something
like that so it inputs a vector
potentially High dimensional
vector and it outputs also a high
dimensional Vector so this is the sort
of
mode of operation and the operations
within each layer are very simple this
is do a matrix Vector multiply so you
have a matrix Vector multiply with a
weight Matrix add a bias vector and do a
nonlinear Activation so these are the
three things we have a bias Vector a
weight Matrix and a matrix Vector
multiply and a nonlinear activation and
you keep on doing it you keep on doing
it and so on of course that there is
more structure to it in general but this
is the simplest construction that you
can you can imagine so the contention of
these authors was the following that if
you want to work with infinite
Dimensions all that we have to do is to
generalize this construction to take as
inputs and outputs not vors functions
right because uh here everything for a
neural network it's vectors input
vectors output all that we have to do is
to take function inputs and function
outputs right and this is what it does
it is also a composition of layers as
you could expect and each layer now for
Simplicity I just map the function space
to itself but there is nothing nothing
Sak or about that so you take a function
space you take a function and you get
out a function let's say that I take a
function V which belongs to X I take my
script n which is the layerwise neural
operator and I produce a w which also
belongs to X just for Simplicity it
could belong belong to a y but it
belongs to X so this is the basic
construction and in order to realize
this construction we have to find
analoges we have to find extensions of
the following objects so instead of the
I have to generalize a bias Vector to
infinite
Dimensions this as you can imagine will
be pretty straightforward right we have
to generalize the weight Matrix or the
Matrix Vector multiply to infinite
dimensions and we have to do the
activation function in infin
Dimensions if I can provide these
ingredients then in principle I have
extended something which is essentially
a finite dimensional construct into
Infinite Dimension everyone agrees with
me this is a very straightforward uh
sort of a sort of a thing and how we do
this of course is where the action is
where the fun is right so let me just
try to explain to you how we do this the
first thing remember that there are
three ingredients I have the V Vector I
have the Matrix vector multip and have
an
activation so remember that now my n
okay this is NL but let me for
Simplicity I don't even know why I put
an L there but let me put an N here N is
a mapping which takes function to
function so my w is equal to n of V okay
so this is the setting that I'm going to
work with that I'm working with the
Matrix uh I'm working with a function
input and a function output
right so of course I need a bias I have
to replace my bias Vector with a bias
function and this is straightforward so
instead of having a bias Vector you just
add a bias function right so instead of
a vector just take a function of course
in practice we have to deal with large
vectors but this is a function the
harder part is what happens to the
Matrix Vector
multiply okay so here we need a little
bit of thinking but not too much of
thinking because essentially
what we do with the Matrix Vector
multiply I have to write a few things
here is that let's think of it so
remember that I have u a of Y remember
this was a of Y which is of course uh
pointwise so a of Yi is nothing but
summation of a i j y j right so this is
what a matrix Vector multiplier looks
like now what would be an infinite
dimensional analog to it in infinite
Dimensions what would happen is that
this object okay maybe I give you the
answer and then you see why it is an
infinite dimensional analog so infinite
dimensional analog to a matrix Vector
multiplier which is given here is given
by what are called kernal
integrals okay and they are given by
this object
here so now remember that I don't have a
vector I have a function right so my
function is given by a v
so I take the function at each point and
I multiply it with a kernel okay so
kernel of course by by definition has
two arguments X and A Y so just like
you'll see what is the analog in a
second so we have uh X and A Y I
multiply this and I integrate over y so
then I get a value WX right or W bar of
X so it's a way in which I can use a
linear operator to go from a function to
a function and why is is an analog of
course it's an obvious analog that you
can you just have to use a
quadr let's even do Monte Carlo quadr
right so Monte Carlo is the simplest you
just take some random points in D and
you're going to approximate this object
here you're going to approximate it by 1
/ M summation of J from 1 to
M of K of i j let me write down K of i j
v J and what is K of i j k of i j is
nothing but the kernel at x i y j and VJ
is nothing but V of XJ so you take Point
values on a grid and you take the values
of the kernel on a grid then you get
precisely this form so now you can see
that this is precisely the same form as
before of course we have a scaling
Factor but this we can push the scaling
Factor inside right so the discrete
version of a colel integral operator is
precisely a matrix Vector multip okay so
if you have a matrix Vector multiply and
you want to work in a function space
version of it that is a c inte so this
is also obvious me it takes two two
lines here of argumentation and all of
you are convinced ah this is the right
infinite dimensional analog right so
this is a very simple infinite
dimensional analog good so we have
replaced this by the bias function this
by The Matrix Vector multiply by the
colal integral operator and then we are
left with just one ingredient remember
that there are three ingredients in a
simple neural network the third
ingredient is non in
activation now the simplest thing you
can do here is just pointwise activation
what do I mean by that so if you have a
function okay let's directly work with
it because then we we are sort of
running out of time so if so this is the
fine part of the neural operator right
so now all that you have to do is to so
now if you evaluate it at any point x
you can evaluate this you can evaluate B
at that point and you can evaluate this
integral at that point all that you do
is to act on this pointwise what does it
mean so take these values let me call it
by a
w so s of w is nothing but acting at X
is nothing but s uh no Sigma acting at w
of X so you evaluate the function at any
point point and then apply r or evaluate
the function at any point and apply the
hyperbolic tangent or Swig glue or G
glue or whatever the entire zoo of
activation functions that we have so
you're done right so you have a infinite
dimensional generalization of the all
that you have done is you have replaced
the bias vector by a bias
function you have replaced the Matrix
Vector multiply by a kernel integral
operator and you have replaced the not
you have not even replaced it you have
just realized the activation point but
so you have an automatic recipe of how
to construct these objects right so
where is the catch there so what are the
learning parameters they are in this BL
means this is uh this is a function
right we have to learn this function and
we have to also learn a kernel K of L so
all the learning parameters are hidden
here but once you have done that you do
that from data you have a new so this
was the contention of these people right
it turns out that there is a little C
yeah even for the realization of these
things because at the end of the day how
are we going to store a function right
we can't store functions we have to sort
of store them in some finite dimensional
representation how are we going to
compute the integrals exactly we can't
compute integrals exactly we have to use
a quadrature and so on so there are some
computational issues with this
construction but in terms of just the
construction in terms of just an
abstract framework this is very nice
right because it provides you a very
simple one toone correspond respondence
between neural networks and let's say
neural operators but after the break
what we're going to see is what are the
difficulties here where do we get stuck
okay and uh we start from there okay so
let's meet at uh just for Simplicity
let's meet at 10 past okay 10 past uh so
12 minutes is enough I think as if we
are sort of running out of time
otherwise post recording
okay so welcome back and let's see how
we realize these things in practice
right so
now so what is the computational
realization of these objects so per
layer you already see the issue but let
me
explain
so so at every layer
layer so I will not give you the layer
index I will simply give you the final
answer so NV of X was given by Sigma
this
activation then you have some bias P of
X Plus The Matrix Vector multiply K of
XY B ofy
Dy right so this is uh how it is at at
the level of functions but in in
practice we have to work with discrete
objects so of course we have to work the
simplest thing is to work with grid
points on a grid so instead of V of V
the function V what we can do is we can
work with Point values which is
completely
fine if you have band limited functions
for instance J from 1 to let's say n
right so this is uh these are the these
are the values similarly K the kernel
which is a two dimensional function so K
will be approximated by so let's do this
k i j which is K
of okay this is YJ sorry K of x i y j
right and now I and J are from 1 to n
so okay so this is the this is the
throughput here and similarly for B so B
of X is going to be approximated by BJ
which is p of
XJ so we have replaced the functions by
this uh discrete vectors and we'll
replace the integral with the quadrature
so integral of T of K of
XY
VY Dy can be approximated by summation
over J some weights so these are the
quad weights Omega J of k i j so this is
VJ right so this and then the finite
dimensional realization so NV at the
point I so this is the r point I is
given by Sigma it looks very much like a
neural network right except that there
is one little catch here so this is BJ
Plus or bi sorry plus summation over J
of Omega j a i j VJ the Omega is just
the quadri we this could be 1/ M for
instance if you do mon something right
so the J is from 1 to n so n is the
number of GD points or the number of
points that you have so what is the
computational cost of going from one
function to another function right so
the computational cost would be so this
is I is from 1 to n
right so for each I how many operations
do you do so at least of the order of n
operations so the total is of the order
of n squ
operations now what is this n n is the
number of grid
points number of grid
points and this in particular is given
by some m to the power d right so in one
dimension you just have 10 points in two
Dimensions it will be 100 points 10 squ
in three dimensions th000 points and so
on so the total operation count is of
the order of m ^
2D so it grows exponential in dimension
and it's quadratic the growth not linear
so in some sense you can see that
already there is a this is this is an
issue that we have to deal with right
because we have a big cost of
computation so just imagine that you're
in QB which is the standard thing that
we often deal with and you're doing
processing on 100 by 100 grid okay so
this is a grid on which you have the
inputs and outputs so now you have
10,000 points right and the
computational cost is going to be 10,000
* 10,000 which is 100 million so per l
it is going to be 100 million and if you
have 10 layers it will be a billion
operations and this is already on a very
very small grid this is and this is just
the basic number right because we also
have to evaluate the bias Vector you
have to do this you have to do that the
very basic number is already a billion
uh operations for a very very simple
Network and that's that's unaffordable
very very quickly and this is also not
necessary right so we need to have some
basic structure so this is why I
explained this particular caveat which
is that there is a computational
complexity a large computational
complexity which is inherent because
it's essentially taking MLPs into
Infinite dimensions and you know the
reason why we don't work with MLPs in
finite Dimensions is because in general
they comput they have other issues with
them but they they have
computational already at the Baseline
they have computational serious
computational complexity issues right
some people have suggested different
kinds of operators we will we will look
at many of
them so so for instance there are what
are called low rank neural operators
graph neural operators multiple neural
operators and so on there's a whole
whole zoo of these objects which try to
confront this computational problem head
on how do I do a compression how do I go
away from this quadratic cost and
arguably the most successful version of
it um is something which we're going to
already seen a bit of that in the
tutorial but this is what we're going to
look a little bit more closely and
little bit more close deeply what are
called f neural operators
or otherwise called as fno so this is
widely considered to be let's say the
most let's say popular at least of all
the neural operators that are there it
has been around now for a few years uh
very well cited and so on so what are
the what are the structural properties
that it uses and I I'll give you a
little bit of detail here so that so
that you understand what's going on of
course you have also implemented this in
the
tutorials okay so what is the what is
the basis of FIA neural
operators so the key here as one of you
suggested to me during the break is that
this kernel is what this kernel integral
operator which is this Matrix infinite
dimensional analog of the Matrix Vector
multiply this is the bottleneck right
because this is where this quadratic
cost comes from so how can we sort of
solve that
problem so the first thinking about it
which is also how CNN's came into being
in the first place is that there is no
reason to consider General kernels okay
the first condition is what if we do a
translation inv variant
kernel so translation in varant kernel
gives you a special structure of the
kernel that the kernel this is exactly
what what happens in CNN so you have a
translation in variant kernel now which
is given by K of x minus y right so and
the the inductive bias here is that a
lot of the inputs and outputs that you
see in physics are translation invit so
this is automatically at least in this
particular form it's it's a motivation
right so now this Cel which was given in
the general form here is precisely a
convolution because this is K of xus y v
of y
d so it's a convolution okay we back
into CNN we could have also used
convolutions there right but the key
trick what these people came up with is
that so convolutions automatically
reduce the cost right because now
instead of a dense Matrix that is being
multiplied you have a sparse Matrix
which is being multiplied so this is
somehow the key trick but now what they
said is that okay instead of performing
convolution in physical space why don't
we perform it in FIA space and you'll
see that there is a payoff because we we
saw what was the issue with convolution
at the beginning of the lecture right so
by doing it in Foria space you do
overcome some profits and to do anything
in Fier space we have to work with a
Fier transform right so so what is the
Fier transform if the function would
have been just periodic I could have
just used fora series but here it's uh
in generally have to work with the F
transform the F transform script of f is
a mang which takes the function okay it
takes a function and it turns out the
frequencies that that's roughly what it
is so now I have given it in some
generality in some detail or in some
because my point is that these functions
they are defined on a domain d right and
they are okay fora coefficients are
complex values so we have taken the
General in generality you have taken
complex valued functions here but they
need not means the the imaginary Parts
could easily be zero so this is a
generalization whenever you work with a
for transform one one typically works
with a complex valued functions they
could be real value and the key here is
that these are vector functions okay
because just imagine that the air
outside the features are not just given
by the temperature the temperature the
pressure the wind velocity humidity
precipitation whatever so these are
vector functions so just just to keep
the generality and the J now here is
giving the vector index here okay so you
can also think of J as not being there
everything being a scalar but I have to
present things in some a little bit of
generality so the F transform is given
in terms of what is called the
trigonometric basis so this is the
complex exponential SS and cosiness
because because in general you cannot
rule one out or the other and then what
you do is that you take the function
which is uh square integrable at the
very minimum so that these integrals are
well defined and you turn out the
frequencies and the frequencies are
defined on the lce right so the D is the
underlying space Dimension the
frequencies are defined on a ltis and
the K is frequency so the K is a vector
now it's a d Vector uh is given by just
taking the function multiply it with the
trigonometric the case trigonometric
polinomial and integrate but this is
just a for transform all of you have
known this since analysis one or two
right so everyone knows all that you do
is to represent the function in terms of
its SC frequencies now there is a you
can get back from frequency space back
into physical Space by using the inverse
fio transform uh F inverse so this is a
mapping which takes values on a lce so
just let's take the two dimensional of
it
right so the frequencies are
discrep just these are integers right we
don't take continuous frequencies these
are discrete so let's say that this is
one frequency this is another frequency
and so on so you have been given the
values of the frequencies and you want
to reconstruct the function all that you
do is that you take the corresponding
frequencies and you form the sort of the
basis expansion with the trigonometric
basis so there's a one to one
correspondence between physical space
and frequency space you can work with
one or you can work with the other and
the idea behind what these people it was
jongi Lee from calte was the first
author in this paper what they
essentially proposed is to work with Fu
space we do many many things in fuia
space you know there are numerical
methods spectral methods which work in
fuia space so why not use them right and
this seems to be very very successful uh
in different ways let me let me explain
that so now the basis is the uh is the
fact that we do convolution in for space
right so there's a cartoon here or a
representation but let me try to explain
what what really goes on here the most
important thing uh let's see if I have
the space to do it generally I clutter
up all the all the space but uh let's
see okay so remember that at the end of
the day I'm carrying out my convolution
K convol with v in f space so all of you
know that when I take the Foria
transform of a convolution what happens
to that so Foria multiplication very
good so this is the one thing I remember
from my harmonic analysis classes is
that this becomes a
multiplication so this is in physical
space this is in physical space in
Furious space this becomes a
multiplication now I want to come back
to physical space what do I do I take
the inverse for transform right so you
take the inverse for transform so so
this means that I have F inverse of f of
K * F of
V okay so now this is the this is the
throughput here so
sorry so of course we have to do it we
have to realize it at a discret level
and this I'm going to tell you in the in
the next slide but now just for the sake
of argument here just for the sake of
understanding let's think that we can
work with functions right if we can work
with function functions so what do I do
I take a function I compute it for
transform okay then I do a
multiplication with a kernel this multip
this kernel could be either it could be
in physical space but I can also do it
in Furious space who stops me from doing
that so this I will write as a
sorry this I'll write as an R here so
this guy here I'll call as an R so this
is just a fora multiplier I do this this
is a learnable object and then I take a
inverse FIA transform and this is
precisely so remember that this thing is
this layers layers layers so these are
this FAL layers and let's unroll one of
these FIA layers so you take a function
to take its FIA transform there is there
is a trick here that I'm going to tell
you in a in a bit but when we do the
discrete realization so what the f
transform does is that it sort of gives
you different frequencies of the
function you multiply this FIA
multiplier you get back some frequencies
and and you take some inverse per
transform so that is the that is sort of
the basic workflow here right so once
you do this then we have nonlinearity we
have the bias Vector so you bias Vector
is just this B of X right you just add
it so there's nothing nothing special
about that but there are a few
additional tricks here that let me let
me explain to you so the point is that
we have to parameterize the kernel in
FIA
space and this bias Vector is not that
important let's for for Simplicity today
let's set it to zero let's focus on what
is important so we set the bi Vector to
zero bass function to zero this can be
readily added there are three additional
ingredients that give the power to this
method so these are this P here okay
this Q here and the W here so the p and
I'll explain that in a in a second these
are very easy operators to explain so
this p is what is called a
projection Q is what is no by the way
WR okay so p is what is called a
projection brain is my brain is not
because brain is simply not
working
lifting Q is what is called a Rec
construction or a projection this is
their notation not mine I would not have
used this notation right because it's
sort of non-intuitive but I want to be
sort of have some consistency with the
code and this W here represents a
residual
connection all the symbols are sort of
not nicely done but this is from their
paper so I I sort of stay residual
connection maybe in the next uh version
of the course I use my own notation okay
so what are these lifting projection and
residual connection layers they are they
very simple so let's start with P so p
is essentially what is also called a
channel
augmentation so remember that my input
is a vector function right in general
it's not a Scala it's a vector function
so V is a mapping from D to let's say r
n okay so what the P does is just a
linear General you can you can make it
into an MLP some people use an MLP but
the simplest version of it is it's it's
just taking P takes this mapping V and
it produces a PV okay PV is a function
so PV belongs to PV is in
R now I'm out of notation let me call it
as some M where m is much bigger than M
so in other words it takes uh let's say
pressure density velocity and so on so
these are the natural variables in which
we describe our system these are the
features and then what it does is that
it says okay who says that the machine
learning algorithm will use the same
features let's endow it with some
additional features these additional
features may or may not have any
physical representation typically they
don't have any physical representation
so you take a vector which is four
dimensional your input which is four
dimensional physical or onedimensional
let's say temperature which is physical
and you take it to 100 Dimensions I'm
just giving a number 100 is not that
uncommon right so this tells you that
already from the data we have we are
equipping it with some additional
features some additional channels okay
it's very very common in image
processing where you take RGB but then
you suddenly expand it to I don't know
12 channels or 16 channels 128 channels
this is a very very common trick or a
very very common realization intuitively
it says that we don't know what features
the machine learning model is going to
use in its algorithm so let us provide
it with the possibility of additional
features okay so this is what uh this
lifting operator does it takes the input
and it lifts it to a let's say not a
higher Dimension physical in physical
space but in feature space okay so it's
a Feature Feature space lifting and
projection is just the inverse of that
so you you lift it to a high dimensional
feature space you do all your processing
in a high dimensional phys feature space
m dimensional feature space and then you
want to come back to your physical space
because at the end of the day I only
have information about my temperature
pressure density humidity things like
that right so projection is just the
opposite it takes W which belongs to RM
pointwise and then it produces Q of w
belongs to
RM M and M okay so this these are this
lifting and projection operators these
are linear they are learnable right we
are going to learn them during the
learning process because we don't know
what are the features if you knew then
that would be the point about machine
learning is to have as little human
crafted and as much end to endend learn
features as possible okay so this is
this is a way to automate that it's very
very common in computer vision to do
that and some of these features I can
have a scientific intuitive
interpretation but I don't need to okay
and the last point is that clear what we
do with this very simple just um Matrix
essentially discretly we will see it in
a second how this is done discretly it's
just a matrix and then uh we do the
processing okay and then what is this
one here this is a residual connection
or a weight Matrix essentially let me
write it down so remember that you have
a sigma you have your convolution kernel
which is done in Fier space now right B
ofy
Dy plus now this is the fun part of it
so this is top view of V of
X okay so you take each point and you
have a learnable representation this is
like a essentially residual connection
this is a parallel route here is all the
processing which is happening here no
processing is happening except for
keeping some information from the
previous step okay so that's why it's a
residual Connection in machine learning
it's useful to have this residual
connections so that you have better
gradient properties essentially and it
turns out we have done some analysis of
this
that this particular map here is very
very important okay so this is again
linear does not depend on space at all
it just depends on the features right so
you can some people also call it as
Channel mixing because all that you're
doing is that you're mixing up the
different features together in some form
right so this is fno at a continuous
level so what do I do I take a function
I'm I've set the bias to zero that's not
important I keep some of the I mix some
of the features of this function locally
at each point in space means uh so this
gives you some Global Information
somehow right because all the points are
the
same let's say the same um constant that
is multiplying the same Matrix that is
multiplying and then I do things in f
space I take F transform do a f
multiplier take a inverse F transform
add them up and pass them to the
nonlinear and I keep on doing it right
so how is the processing done you take a
function you take your input function
you add channels to it do the fua
processing and the residual connection
FIA processing residual connection F
processing residual connection at the
output projected back to your original
feature space and you have your answer
okay so this is how it is done at the
level of functions this is a very simple
architecture in some sense and we will
see that these computational complexity
caveats that we had these are somehow
very nicely resolved because we we do
things in Furious space there's one
trick here which is that we we need to
compute the foror transform and we need
to compute the inverse foror transform
right we've been given a function of
course we do it pointwise so we have to
compute a discrete foror transform and a
discrete inverse foror transform so this
all of you know can be done very very
fast through fft right so we have the
fast for transform and the fft does this
if you are on a grid for instance equ
spaced on a grid this takes you n log
and operations so this is a very very
fast operation okay so is that clear are
there any questions about how fno Works
yes
James frequencies this is what I'm going
to describe exactly in the next slide so
again good anticipation of what I'm
going to do because I've still not given
you the discrete recipient right this is
all at the level of functions but I need
to sort of translate it at the level of
actual vectors great par right there is
what uh because I want
to sort of explain it and I don't have
to explain every every ply little detail
because some of these are very obvious
and then you you understand the thing
that is the most important here is to
work with the F layer right this F
processing
layer I hope I'm recording no
yeah okay so let me try to to precisely
raise address the point that uh James
raised and let's try to understand this
at a discrete level so what do we do and
again I I just look at one layer I'm
assuming that this uh okay let's let's
take let's try to
experience that's why I have a whole
slide blank so that I can fill it
up so remember that I have for each FAL
lay so that you understand what's going
on so for each for layer and now I'm not
going to use a layer index L anymore
right so this is the same across all l
so my input if it was a function would
be given by some V of X right that is a
function but in reality I have a
discrete
input discrete
input which is um VJ which is p of XJ
and this J runs from some one to capital
L so these are points on the grave
because at the end of the day we have to
work with points on the grave there's no
no escape from that and remember that
for each J VJ is in some it could be
complex value but let's let's keep
things simple and it's real value this
is in RM RM is this High dimensional
feature space right so I have lifted to
this High dimensional feature space and
I'm processing along this High
dimensional feature space so I've been
given this Vector but since this Vector
itself has many features I can write it
as a m cross n Matrix for in in
implementation it is usually done as M
cross n Matrix then I do the for
transform right so the next step
is okay so let's take the Foria
transform so in principle if you
remember and this was why James I think
asked the question the for transform
allows you to evaluate any frequency so
if you want the 1,00,000
frequency it can do if you want the
million by million frequency it can do
right you can evaluate any frequency in
practice you cannot do that because that
would be an infinite object and we have
to make approximations so what kind of
approximations can we make we have to
cut it off right so this discrete for
transform is so you have a discrete for
transform discrete for
transform okay so you take this VJs and
then you take uh let me now I'm running
out of notation but let's
try so we had because for transform is
always given but this is V hat of K so
this is the discrete F transform F of
VJ okay so you have values on a grid uh
you take the for transform of this
Matrix and then what you do is that you
have minus capital K less than or equal
to little K less than or equal to
Capital because you have both positive
and negative frequencies so you take
this so in other words what you do is
that you take a signal and you cut it
off into frequencies okay and typically
the the idea is that this 2 k + 1 so
these are the number of frequencies
capital K is less than it could be much
less than the number of points n okay so
this is somehow the key to the
computation complexity as well as a
working it may not be but then you pay
more in terms of computation and
evaluating this for coefficients is fast
this is the fast for transform right it
the complexity is quite nice so you take
it and you do some truncation of the
frequency and this is this is what they
express here that you don't need all the
frequencies you keep only some of the
frequencies you could also do that by
taking a matrix which is uh R which
multiply Matrix and having a lot of
zeros in it but the simplest
conceptually is to think that you take a
signal and you let's say the signal is
on a 100 by 100 grid but you don't have
to keep frequencies 100 by 100
frequencies you see you can keep 20 by
20 frequencies and this is sort of the
in sustance a key Point
here so this is the F transform then is
the F
multiplier for
multiplier so this Matrix now is 2K + 1
by 2 k + 1 * uh 2K + 1 much smaller of
course times um whatever M features
right so you have all these frequencies
in each Direction and then you have M
features then you have F multiplier R
which is uh going to take take these
values and I made a mistake give me one
second it's 2K + 1 of course 2 k + 1
time times
M and then this F multiplier Matrix you
really do it in terms of a tensor so it
takes it and it takes so essentially it
takes C of 2 k + 1 and it produces a
complex number which is 2 k + one for
Simplicity it could be something else so
it takes 20 frequencies and it
transforms them into 20 frequencies it
could transform into 30 frequencies if
you want or 15 if you want to right so
there is this this is learnable so this
is the part which is learnable
and in the code it is realized as a t
one and then you have the inverse
period inverse for your
transform I have to keep some look on
the time otherwise I'll be in trouble
okay so the you take the inverse for
your transform and then uh the weight
Matrix you have this W matrix
multiplication that is Trivial right
because now you just have a point wise
Matrix that just mixes up the features
so essentially the key here is that you
do a FIA transform through fft which is
very fast you truncate it you don't you
only take only few frequencies you do
the REM multiplication with this Foria
Matrix then you take the inverse Foria
transform add to the residual connection
and you keep on processing so the cost
is you see several places where we have
reduced the cost we have taken fft so
that bit is very efficient and you have
taken much smaller much smaller but
smaller sort of
frequency compactification of the entire
thing so that there is also a source of
efficiency and then we keep these things
um in parallel and this is sort of the
somehow the key to this this particular
feature and anyway you have seen this
Construction in the code during the
during the tutorial good so this any
questions on the implementation of the
fno because this is an important
Baseline that we will also consider in
the exercises
yes uh usually that's a very very good
question right usually it's a hyper
parameter and it's sort of there is a
ballpark there are people have done now
experiments for many many years and
somehow 24 16 or not more than
30 you could but no one does it you
could you could do it as a learnable
parameter but then it's harder right
because then the the code becomes very
complicated you have to put several
zeros you have to pad with zeros in
order to keep the so one one you could
you could write that code but what's the
point so it's sort of there is some good
theory to say that you don't need so
many frequencies because remember that
some of the
frequencies uh it's not like you're
killing all the frequencies because just
imagine that you have a signal which has
many non-zero frequencies okay some of
it are a lot of it is also retained
through this guy here because remember
that this guy retains all the
frequencies so you keep a part of the
signal and only a part of the signal is
the high frequencies are kept in some
sense and then the low frequencies are
processed so there is some additional
additional parameterization there okay
so but it's it's a good question 20
order of 20
yes
yes it is it is acting in F but it's
just a matrix or a t the interpretation
is that it is a kernel parameterized in
space but its interpretation is purely
that of a implementation is purely that
of a tensor because it it takes a vector
of frequencies right it transforms them
into another the frequencies but then it
has to be a matrix but because each
frequency has different features it has
to be a tensor of the appropriate order
yes
the where problems when when the
real yeah how do you deal with this
problem uh why is this a problem because
uh okay when the when the real part is
um is
[Music]
negative it's not it's not uh Define and
stable there but if you it's only for
functions which because functions are
typically you are taking band limited
functions in some sense right so you
don't simply have the frequencies that
cause problems yeah further questions
good so keep the questions coming then
we all understand better including
myself so it's always good so now good
so now the point is that um and this I
have to go a little bit quickly because
otherwise we'll be out of time so I'll
end just end up repeating in the next
lecture so it doesn't really help maybe
as I said this are very widely used in
practice we will see some numerical
experiments uh next week probably but
the as one of you asked means the whole
point was to construct Renos right so
are these Renos the answer is yes and no
it's a mixed answer of course Reno the
concept came much later than F so
there's no reason to so there are two
elements to it right so first of all
this lifting and weight Matrix and so on
these are these are just linear
operations which have nothing to do with
space you know they have to do with
channels and so these are by definition
reinforcements they don't change
anything the spatial structure so that
is uh so the two essential things right
so you have a convolution in f space and
you have a
nonlinearity so it turns out that one
can show that if you have the right
spaces X and Y so in particular if you
take periodic band limited functions PK
so this is a space of periodic functions
then there is an automat the convolution
and the reason why the convolution let
me give you the intuitive reason and
then there is there is a proof which is
uh given in terms of this diagram the
reason why it works is because you do
this low dimensional Foria projection so
you might take your signal and any grid
okay so you might take it on a course
Grid or a fine grid but at the end of
the day what you do is that you project
it onto the same for modes and as long
as these for modes have this sist
barrier being satisfied so it does not
matter if I take a 64x 64 Grid or 128 by
128 grid I'm at the end of the day
projecting them onto the same for space
I'm working with this for space so there
is no ambiguity in terms of the
convolution if I would have kept that
changing if I would have changed this SC
with grid then I would be in trouble but
since I don't and this is where the
proof is because a Fier transform of
course is
a for the band limited functions there's
automatic relationship here so this is
in continuous then you're just
multiplying a foror multiplier so you do
nothing here and then you take the
inverse foror transform right and uh you
can just use the Fier basis so this T of
s is simply using the fua basis
pointwise evaluations and then you just
use the fua basis and these diagrams are
all commuting so this is it's a very
simple argument to see why uh if I know
the convolution part of f because unlike
in the previous case where I was keeping
the same kernel here because I working
and then I was getting into trouble
because I was operating in physical
space here by keeping the same sort of
fua multiplier for a fixed FIA space I'm
avoiding that problem okay so of course
the designers of f didn't have those
considerations in mind but this is what
it turns out to be however it's not just
the convolution right you also have a
non linearity and this is where the
trouble is and let me explain to you
where the trouble
is so so the point is that uh all this
is done if you take the right spaces if
you have a right connection between the
continuous and discreet and this is
provided by for instance band limited
functions right because then you know
that certain frequencies can't be
Amplified certain frequencies are
completely damp down and so on and so
forth now when you take nonlinearities
uh you you really get into trouble so
let me explain to you why because let's
say that you have a function which has
10 nonzero frequencies so it has sin x s
2x sin 10 x and so on now you take the
simplest nonlinearity that you can think
of the square right you take the square
of sin 10x what do you get sin 20x right
because and then of course you have
started with 10 frequencies and you
automatically end up with 20 frequencies
so nonlinearities what they do is that
they can break the structure they can
introduce additional frequencies and
this is where the trouble is and this is
best shown in this picture
here so I've have taken a signal let me
use black maybe I've taken a signal
which is in Orange so this is the signal
and I've applied different
nonlinearities to it okay so I've just
used the neist frequency as a barrier
let's just focus on reu because jell is
just a smooth inversion of it reu as you
can see it Clips all the negative parts
right and it just keeps the positive
parts so this is where reu works now in
frequency space the same function so
these are the frequencies so as you can
see I have taken 20
frequencies uh my original function had
20 frequencies but as soon as I applied
a loop you see my original function it
remained within the frequency bals right
but as soon as I pr Lop I have this
leakage you see that there is this
leakage which is happening and this
leakage means that I'm introducing high
frequencies and because I'm introducing
high frequencies I break the band limits
and even if my convolution keeps them if
my convolution provides that structure
because I'm using know linearities which
are not keeping the band limits you end
up in from okay so even if one part of
chain works the other part of the chain
does not activations are going to
introduce high frequencies these are not
necessarily resolved in the grid and
that causes aing so this is roughly what
what the story with fno is and let me
give you a couple of examples just to
illustrate that and then we
finish the first one is a very dramatic
example it's not a PD example example PD
in pdes what happens is that frequencies
have some Decay as a whole point very
high frequencies are damped down but
this is an example where high
frequencies can remain high okay so it's
an assignment problem it's a random
assignment it's a perfectly cure well-
defined operator so what you do is that
you have some inputs which is a random
field and output is also a random field
and you just assign different points
randomly across okay well defined
operator not containing but measurable
so all the everything should apply to it
and then when you train it on a
particular grd so it is trained on 61 by
61 one is because of this 2K + 1 okay 61
by 61 it is 30 frequencies and you can
see whether I take the CNN or the fno at
this resolution they almost give no no
error right you can you can easily learn
and then I just evaluate the output on
different grids as soon as I change even
one grid point
all hell breaks loose so here the neist
barrier is not satisfied anymore okay
since the neist barrier is not satisfied
anymore you can you can't expect that
the errors will remain low because the
bijection that we had is broken but here
the nous barrier is satisfi so we should
expect that errors are low but they are
not right almost immediately as you can
see both for CNN because the convolution
itself has issues as well as for f
because here the nonlinearity has issues
you don't have the same resolution the
errors are very very large of course
this problem has been constructed in
order to make it extreme okay so in some
sense it is a contrived example so the
nonlinearity not uh preserving the band
limits leads to that issue it turns out
that even in Practical problems you
cannot avoid it even though the people
who invented fno thought that they could
get away with it because the errors
would be low but that is not the case so
this was uh CNN unit but it's it's
essentially CNN and you remember that
how the results where so we have the
mapping between the velocity and the in
the beginning initial velocity and final
velocity for Navia Stokes and this is
the corresponding verticity so you start
with some sheia and then you start
introducing VES so if you take fno O
then what happens is that uh you end up
with with trouble even in this part here
the neist barrier is satisfied so
there's no reason why it shouldn't be
but you can see that there are very
reasonably large increases in error here
on the other hand there is an increase
in error but it's not as dramatic as
before right so it was but it's not zero
so it's there is aliasing error because
the high frequencies are damed down so
you can see that the error goes from I
don't know 3.6% to around 3.8% there's a
mild growth and if you would have
continued it would have continued
growing probably in this direction so by
design it is not a know in this
particular case it didn't lead to as
many problems particularly when you
evaluated it at highly resolved higher
resolved me measures but in in principle
it can it can lead to problems right
because CNN both the nonlinearity as
well as the convolution broke the band
limits so of course it was it was worse
so compared to CNN of course fno is
better but it's not a solution in that
in this particular sense it's widely
used but there is there is an issue so
we still have this challenge which is to
design something which is genuinely
operator learning rather than just
learning Maps between particular finite
Dimensions to particular fins okay and
this is what we will do on Friday and we
continue also next week good so we
finish a bit early but we also took uh
less time during the break bye-bye